普通の人々の場合は この無明っていうのはこの静かにこの猫の子猫のように寝ているものじゃないんです
どんどんこの子猫が成長し
成長して成長して 巨大な大虎ぐらいに大きくなっちゃうんです
猫も虎ぐらいに大きくなったら人を食うんです
で そういうわけでアーサヴァがつある
このつは心所でき数えればローバとディッティとモーハ
三つ その心所の三つがこういうすごい働きをしてくれる
そこでこの人間のこの輪廻の問題
解脱できない問題はこの漏にあるんです
心所の漏的な働きにあるんです
漏れる働きにあるんです
ですから 修行者がその漏れる働きについては大変気をつけなくちゃいけない
そういうわけで あまりにもこのつが大事だから
カーマ ババ ディッティ
アヴィッジャとつが違うマーティカでまた同じことを言うんです
次のマーティカがオーガ
ボリュウ？ボリュウですね
え？ボル？ボルっていうのはシンハラ語で嘘っていうことですけど
で ボルというこの流れる
それ激流なんですね で
そういう激流に激流に人が入ってしまったら
どうにもないでしょうに
流れのままに流されるしか道がないんです
トーナードに捕まっちゃったらもうどうしようもないでしょう
トーナードなんて言いますか
竜巻 アメリカによくあるでしょうね
で それもそれに捕まってしまっちゃったら
もう死亡を告げた方がいいんです
そこですごい洪水で 水がものすごいボルにボルとして流れて強力に流れていくと
もう諦めた方がいいんですね
そこの中に入っちゃったら
そこでこのカーマ ババ
ディッティ アヴィッジャという同じつが
このボルという言葉で新しくまたカテゴリーに入れてるんです
なぜボルかというと カーマに入ってしまったら
欲に入ってしまっちゃったらどうしようもない
流されちゃうんです もう逃げる道がない
だから我々は一般に頑張って生きてるわけじゃないんです
生かされているというか
何ですかね 流されてるんです
生きるということで 欲に流されてるだけ
私は泳いでるんだよとこういうの思うと大違うんです
この激流に入る もう落ちちゃって
激流に流されてるだけ
だから人間というのはカーマ
ババ ディッティ アヴィッジャというこのつの心所で流されてるんです
輪廻の輪廻 例えば私は金持ちになりたいんだから
自分で頑張って金持ちになったぞと威張るでしょうね
あれものすごいアホな言い方なんですね
真理は知らないんだからね
ただ欲が生まれたんだから
バカみたく操られただけなんです
徹底的に で あの子供を産んでる動物たちがね
子供いると必死になって子供育てるでしょうに
あれはまあ 何愛？え？何？ 溺れる
まあまあまあ そういう難しいことじゃなくて
この例えばみんな言うでしょ？やっぱりまあ母はね
大変子供のこと愛情で母性愛母性愛で一生懸命育てているんだとか
全く嘘なんです あれ 単なるこの欲
欲でもう流されてるだけ
その世の中 その美しいことそうないんです
であのあのタコとかね
子供の卵を産んだら死ぬまで卵に綺麗な水をかけてるでしょうね
タコの母親が それで何ヶ月
1ヶ月とかに 3ヶ月とかぐらいずっといっぱい卵をでしょうね
それで卵を何か穴の中に入れてたくさんありますから
その穴を自分で体でもう隠して
体で完全に隠すわけにはいきません
いつでも綺麗な水が必要なんです
それで口でずっと水を吹いてるんです
で 休んじゃったらすぐ魚が来て
卵をもう一服さひく取っていっちゃうんですね
だから周りいつでも魚が待ってるんです
自分の目の周り だからいつでもこの自分を穴をね
塞ぐ 締めを締めをするんですね
閉めちゃったら水が効かないんだから
また開けなくちゃいけない
開けちゃったらすぐ魚がその中から入ってくる
それで頑張って頑張って
とにかくずっと 24時間も休みなく水をもう吹き込んだりする
吹き込んだりするんだけど
どんどん力が尽きますから
卵を狙われちゃう あっちこっちから
そこでやっと卵が孵化する頃になっちゃうと
あの母タコがボロボロボロボロ倒れちゃうんです
倒れて死んじゃうんです
死ぬかどうかは分かりませんだけど
もう動かないんだから
他の魚たちが来て 何のことなくもうパクパクって食べちゃう
そこで命が終わると だからすごい美しいでしょ
母が命かけて子供育てると
NHK の何とか自然の番組だったらすごい美しく感動的に
書くんだけど 仏教から見れば何のことないんです
あれは その母の心に生まれたこの欲という
感情でやらされてるだけ
ですから それぐらい理解しなきゃ悟りにはすごい遠いんですよ
悟りっていうのはものすごい知恵の世界だから
ぼーっとしてる世界ではないんです
ものすごい鋭い世界ですから
あれ感情で見る見るんじゃないんです
仏教はね 高度なレベルでは知恵で見るんです
そういうわけで 欲というものはボルとして
あのオーガ オーガっていうのはまあいわゆる香水
ものすごい力強い香水にしているんです
だから欲の香水が心に生まれたら
我々はその欲のまんまで何でもする
だから だから欲と似ているのは慈悲も似てますけど
感情としてはね 人を大事にすること
生命を愛することも欲と似てますけど
でもボロにはならないんですね
残念ながら 欲だったら
例えば自分の子だったら
もういくら家が火事になってもうもう倒れかけていたっても
母親がもう母が中に飛び出して飛び込んで子供を探す可能性はあります
現代あまりやらないかもしれませんだけど
一応そういう可能性はあります
どう見たっても もう家に入ったっても
もう出てこられないとわかっても
もう子供が中にいても
もうもうどうしようもないとわかっても
それでもやっぱり見てみるという気持ちになる可能性あります
で 慈悲はそれぐらいになりたたないんです
ボロにならないんですね
慈悲はボロになったら同じことをしますけどね
自分が死んだっても やっぱり人を死なせるわけにはいきませんと
助けろとね そこまでなる
ですから ボロになるのはやっぱり欲なんです
だから説明する必要ないんです
とにかく名前だけでいいんです
カーマ 欲 存在欲 生きていきたいということ
それからジャケン 見解
それからモミョ ものすごいパワーになっちゃうんです
見解のこと知ってるでしょうに
いろんなことを教え込まれちゃったら
人々はもうどんなことにでも
例えばね もう人殺しにも
で 麻原現象にしたって同じことでしょうに
見解作って もう子供たちに刷り込まれて若者に
それでもう膨大な資金集めて
じゃあこれから人殺しに行こうではないかと
人殺しに行くぜと 世界直しますよと
それで で そこまでヘリックスも通じるんです
見解では だから基本的に考えれば
仏教は慈悲だから いくらなんでも人殺しはいけませんでしょう
先生ということにはならないんですね
だから見解ってそういうふうなことで
もう入っちゃったら何でもやってしまっちゃう
自分の主義を守るために何でもすると
共産主義の人々はね いろんな汚いことをやってきたんではないんですかね
母親よりは共産党が大事ですよと
次にヨーガ ヨーガっていうのは
これの読み方は ん？ヤク？クビキじゃん
読めば四役なんですが
まあ釘ではいいんです
それも同じことで 言葉だけのことなんですね
このヨーガという言葉は
まあわざわざ使っているヨーガという言葉はヒンズー教でありますからね
ヨーガやるんだとかね
まあ修行にもヨーガということを知ってます
使ってますからね で 仏教でも修行にもヨーガという言葉を使っているので
ヨーガってどのようにできたかというと
このつなげるというか
きちんとこのはめ込むということなの
釘だからね でもうヨーガの場合は魂
絶対的な魂に自分の魂を入れてはめ込んで
もう一体にしてもう逃げられないようにすると
ということでヨーガと
で そんなことしなくたってば人はもう輪廻転生しているんだからね
何しなくたって輪廻転生するんです
だからあの人とバカバカらしくて怖がってるんです
死んじゃったら困るんだと
永遠にならなくちゃいけないんだと
どうしたっても死なないんです
前も説明したでしょうに
死ということをアビダンマでなかなか定義しにくいんだから
もうずっと続くんですからね
それは嫌だから仏教でやめなさいと言うだけであって
人間というのは一時的な身体だけ見て
これが私だと それで死んじゃったら困るんだから
じゃあ梵我一如でもしようかなと
全部もう無茶苦茶の考え方なんですね
とにかくそういうことで
なんでこんなに生きることは苦しみなのに
人間が輪廻転生したいかと
人間が輪廻転生したい
解脱はしたくない それはこの四つのふびきですからなんです
それもカーマ 体を楽しみたいということ
それから生きてきたいと
輪廻したいという気持ち
輪廻したいと思わなくてももうするんだからね
それでもやりたいと思っちゃうんですね
それからディッターサは見解と無明
その四つはものすごいキーポイントなんです
だから怒りはキーポイントになってない
覚えておいてください
欲と見解と無明と その三つが
四つと言ったって はキーポイントなんです
だから四聖諦の中でお釈迦様は渋滞として渇愛だけ取ってるんです
怒りなどは取ってないんです
というわけで ただいい加減なリストじゃない
このリストいろいろバラバラなんですけど
そのバラバラであることも大変なわけがあるんです
本当に心の働きを見て
そういうのは言ってるんです
それでまたガンと もう時間はなくなりました
どうしますかね 悪いところで今日終わった方が良かったのに
ここら辺は終わっ--
この章終わったら残るのはあれなんですね
アビダンマどこも終わりまでやるかやらないかまた決まってない
アビダンマ終わるまでやるところ
これ終わったら今まで分析論をやってきたんですね
仏教では 分析論終わったら
この何て言いますか シンセサイズの法則やらなくちゃいけない
組み合わせ ものは分析してバラバラでいるわけじゃないんだから
組み合わせ論はやらなくちゃいかな
だから分析してからどのように現象が組み合わされますかっていう
それ因果法則と因縁の教えなんですね
これちょっと難しいところはありますけどね
それから悟りの科学ですか
悟りの心理学的なプロセスということでアビダンマ終わるんですが
一応何回で終わるかっていうことは決めるならば
それでまとめて 今日はそこら辺で終了します
[背景音]